Dear Fellow Scholars, this is Two Minute Papers
with Dr. Károly Zsolnai-Fehér.
I hope you like wiggles and jiggles, because
today… we are going to a see a lot of them.
You see, this technique promises to imbue
a rigged animation with elastoplastic secondary
effects.
Now, if you tell this to a computer graphics
researcher, they will be extremely happy to
hear that this is finally possible, but what
does that really mean?
This beautiful fish animation is one of the
finest demonstrations of the new method.
So, what happened here?
Well, the first part means that we modeled
a piece of 3D geometry, and we wish to make
it move, but in order to make this movement
believable, we have to specify where the bones
and joints are located within the model.
This process is called rigging, and this model
will be the input for it.
We can make it move with traditional methods,
well, kind of.
You see that the bones and joints are working,
but the model is still solid.
For instance, look…the trunk and ears are
both completely solid.
This is not what we would expect to see from
this kind of motion.
So, can we do better than this?
Well, hold on to your papers, and let’s
see how this new technique enhances these
animations.
Oh yes, floppy ears, also, the trunk is dangling
everywhere.
What a lovely animation!
Prepare for a lot more wiggles and jiggles.
Now, I love how we can set up the material
properties for this method, of course, it
cannot just make decisions by itself because
it would compete with the artist’s vision,
the goal is always to enhance these animations
in a way that gives artists more control over
what happens.
So what about more elaborate models?
Do they work too?
Let’s have a look and find out together!
This is the traditional animation method.
No deformation on the belly, nostrils are
not moving too much, so now, let’s see the
new method.
Look at that.
The face, ears, nose, and the mouth now show
elastic movement.
So cool!
Even the belly is deforming as the model is
running about.
So we already see that it can kind of deal
with the forces that are present in the simulation.
Let’s give this aspect a closer look.
This is the traditional method…we are moving
up and down, up and down.
Alright, but look at the vectors here, there
is an external force field, or in simpler
words, the wind is blowing.
And, unfortunately, not much is really happening
to this model.
But… when we plug in this new technique,
look, it finally responds to these external
forces.
And as a reward, we get more wiggles.
Ha-haa!
So, what else can this do?
A lot more.
For instance, it does not require this particular
kind of rig with the bones and joints.
This hedgehog was instead, rigged with two
handles, which is much simpler, but unfortunately,
when we start to move it with traditional
techniques, …well… leg is kind of pinned
to the ground, where the remainder of the
model moves.
So, how did the new technique deal with this?
Oh yes, the animation is much more realistic,
and things are dangling around in a much more
lively manner.
The fact that it works on many different kinds
of rigged models out there in a wild bolsters
the usability of this technique a great deal.
But we are not done yet.
No-no!
If you have been holding on to your papers
so far, now, squeeze that paper, because we
can take a scene, drop in a bunch of objects,
and expect a realistic output.
But wait a second…if you have been watching
the series for a while, you know for a fact
that for this, we need to run an elaborate
physics simulator.
For instance, just look at this muscle simulation
from earlier.
And here is the key, this animation took over
an hour for every second of video footage
that you see here.
The new method does not need to compute a
full-blown physics simulation to add this
kind of elastic behavior, and hence, in many
cases, it runs in real time.
And it works for all kinds of rigs out there
in the wild, and we even have artistic control
over the output.
We don’t need elaborate models and many
hours of rigging and simulation to be able
to create a beautiful animation anymore.
What
a time
to be alive!
Thanks for watching and for your generous
support, and I'll see you next time!